[Music]
we have this mental image that a flying
saucer will circle the White House lawn
Lanna the White House lawn and give us a
bounty of all sorts of technological
goodies to initiate an Age of Aquarius
on the planet Earth personally I don't
think that's good not gonna happen for
example if you're in the forest do you
go out and talk to the squirrels and the
deer maybe you do for a while but after
a while you get bored because they don't
talk back to you because they have
nothing interesting to tell you because
they don't they can't relate to our
values and our ideas if you go down to
an anthill you go down to the ants and
say I bring you trinkets
I bring you beads take me to your ant
queen I give you nuclear energy so I
think for the most part the aliens are
probably not going to be interested in
us because we're so arrogant to believe
that we have something to offer them
realize that they could be thousands
maybe millions of years ahead of us in
technology and they may have well no
interest in interacting with us in the
same way that we don't necessarily want
to deal with the squirrels and the deer
in the forest now some people say that
we should not try to make contact with
them because they could be potentially
dangerous for the most part I think
they're going to be peaceful because
there'll be thousands of years ahead of
us but we cannot take the chance so I
personally believe that we should not
try to advertise our existence to alien
life in outer space because of the fact
that we don't know their intentions then
the other question is what happens if
they're evil well I think the question
of evil is actually a relative question
because the real danger to a deer in the
forest is not the hunter with a gigantic
rifle he's not the main danger to a deer
in the forest the main danger to a deer
in the forest is the developer the guy
with blueprints the guy in a three-piece
suit the guy with a slide role in
calculator the guy that's going to pave
the forest and
have to destroy whole ecosystems in
other words the aliens don't have to be
evil in order to be dangerous to us they
might not care they just may not care
about us and in the process pave us over
in fact if you read the novel War of the
Worlds
the Martians in htu well seminal novel
we're not evil in this Cynthia wanted to
torture us and they wanted to do all
sorts of barbaric things to humanity no
we were just in the way and so I think
that is a potential problem we could be
in the way of a very advanced
civilization that simply is not evil but
simply views us as we would view
squirrels and deer in the forest so
personally I think that we should not
advertise our existence when we go into
outer space for the most part however I
do think they are going to be peaceful
they're not going to want to plunder the
earth because they're plenty of planets
out there that have nobody on them that
they can plunder at will without having
to worry about restive natives called
humanity and so I think they're not
going to come to visit the earth to
plunder us to do all sorts of mischief
for the most part I think they'll just
leave us alone
[Music]